first of all you just showed me uh
congratulations 90 proof is like the
number three biggest debuted song on
Spotify for the week yeah not just rap
just a song all the genres yeah just uh
just yeah that's hard that's huge man I
know you would appreciate it bro how's
that how's that feel
it's cool it made me want to do some
Moto you know I'm saying I'm just trying
to see what else I can get up you know
what I'm saying get accomplished how did
you uh cause like obviously
um you know going back to those
dreamville sites and [ __ ] like that
would you say that that was kind of like
the origins of you like locking in with
Cole and building that rapport with him
yeah um that's how I really got to tap
in with him but Loki uh I think my
relationship with Jude like was my
relationship with dreamville in general
That's my boy so uh yeah bro like
Cole pulled up on me at jizz like he was
having a lock-in just in L.A and just
attack me dude I turned around and just
called I [ __ ] with you I'm like [ __ ] I
[ __ ] with you that's crazy you know and
that's how I got cool bro but um of
course the sessions down there made up
everybody wagamo cool he made a whole
lot of [ __ ] like brothers yeah it sort
of feels like I feel like everybody's
it's like it was like a fraternity of
whoever was able to like be lucky enough
to be a part of those yeah no [ __ ] for
sure like a fair house bro yeah for real
I heard like uh Giannis was there man
I'm in there I'm talking about Chris
Bosh behind Chris I heard Chris Bosh was
making beats yeah making beats and
Backwoods all kind of [ __ ] going crazy
bro yeah Ludacris was just standing
behind me one day because you would just
be showing your bag you don't realize
who running around that [ __ ] but
yeah that's all that was in there they
was like 19 at the time